it's an honor long overdue for a Vietnam
war hero who risked his life to save
three fellow soldiers nearly six decades
after he was first recommended for the
nation's highest military recognition
retired Colonel Paris Davis was finally
awarded the Medal of Honor at the White
House Friday Catherine Herridge has his
story
58 years after he bore the battle
we honor a true hero of our nation with
that President Biden awarded the Medal
of Honor to 83 year old Paris Davis one
of the first black officers in the
Army's Elite Green Berets Northeast of
Saigon near bangsan in 1965 Davis was
hit by grenade and gunfire during a
19-hour battle in Vietnam among other
acts of heroism Davis rescued his own
wounded soldiers under heavy enemy fire
Davis defied an order to evacuate as he
told Phil Donahue in 1969. I told him
sir I'm just not going to leave I still
have an American out there Davis's
commanding officer Billy Cole
immediately nominated him for the Medal
of Honor but then the records
mysteriously vanished there's still
question is what the devil went on why
did it take so long CBS News sat down
with Davis and his daughter Reagan Davis
Hopper Reagan was race a factor I
suspect it might have been and I think
that's a shame
um so I'm so proud of us to finally set
this right then I took the work of this
diverse group of volunteers many who
didn't know Davis but worked to revive
his case it's it's really very emotional
are you wearing that medal for
the men and women you served with well
mostly for the men and women I serve
with but
it's for America too the retired Colonel
becomes one of 65 living recipients of
the Medal of Honor incredible guy
he's my hero and I'm just so thrilled
that America is going to get to know him
too for CBS Saturday morning Catherine
Herridge the White House
sometimes you see Awards like this
happen after somebody has passed away so
glad that is not the case to do it in
his lifetime and the president said it
was the most consequential day of his
presidency to be able to award this and
you think the paperwork got lost twice
mysteriously mysteriously could you
imagine waiting sometimes you have to
wait unfortunately a real long time for
things but 58 years have that
recognition tremendous good for him